were you raised here I mean in not space
of course in Los Angeles no I was raised
in Washington I only came out here
because Ludwig okay well because so she
was living in a mountain with her 10
moms yeah and then she was watching I'm
in charge of the fire every day yeah
yeah she got to turn the butter and then
she found she she found the computer and
uh everyone was asleep and so she's a
computer and she saw Ludwig streaming
and she was like I have to meet this man
I have to convert him just Googling Dr
Pepper yeah
I have to try this that's just the
[ __ ] thumbnail of Ludwig she's like
who's this who's that man handsome man
drinking caffeine he's doing a soda pop
tier list wow what a bad boy
yeah this is crazy
um yeah streaming before you met Ludwig
yes oh my God yeah something to clear up
I [ __ ] hate that's my biggest thing I
am a self-made woman women no women
don't exist outside man come on now you
know you know this i i i people think I
harp on this but I harp on it because of
the amount of people that call me a
[ __ ] gold digger the amount of people
that like say I'm nothing without him I
had a thousand viewers before I met
Ludwig and he I met him at 300. yeah and
my content was harassing men you know I
want you to do with your controller I
want you to take it and shove it up your
[ __ ] ass um I felt like I'd earned it
yeah let's go after years uh no I'd go
on this thing called the rajler yeah oh
yeah yeah I've seen that Rogers died
since then unfortunately yeah I'd go on
that show and those people just wanted
drama and I very much so would go and
play a character I was very like a I was
like a Regina George or like a CRC
Lannister I was just rude to these
people that's awesome um I was bullied
enough in high school that I know how to
bully other people and roast them and
stuff like that so I would go on I'd
roast all these girls and then I'd
always win the show and I'd get a rate
of 20 000 people I Was A League of
Legends streamer with 20 viewers I did
not know what to do with 20 000 people
so I would go to just chatting and I
would scroll through and I'd find guys
and I'd go in their chat and be like get
on a Discord call with me and I'd call
them and I I'd harass Ben I'd be like do
you want to get a Discord call with me
I'd get on a call with them and we'd
either play games or I would just like
hit on them or whatever like it was just
for show it was all for show and Ludwig
I went to his chat and the first message
in my chat was will you date me and he
made a joke and I was like this guy's
funny and then I moved on I went to
other guys blah blah then I was like
that guy was funny I went back to him
and he messaged me and he's like do you
want to play games together I was like
yeah so I was using him for as long as I
could right I was like this guy's funny
and then all of a sudden this reverse
leech happened and I was like what the
[ __ ] this was not the point yeah and he
just he became bigger and bigger and we
were friends for a really really long
time before we dated the internet I
thought we were dating way before we
ever dated interesting um but yeah it
was
it was love at first message it wasn't
love at first I saw that clip of you
like switching to your Discord and it
says like babe or something like that
yeah you are cringe why are you watching
that's funny I was like get owned dude
why am I cringe you used to be the one
that cringed now look at you you are
that's got like millions of views on
YouTube I know I know it was yeah you
are the one yeah cringes that was like
you are good at bullying January or
something we were like that's when we
were starting to flirt you know I don't
know I thought it was like it was really
cool that Ludwig revealed that's really
cool that you invented that yeah
Ludwig just getting harassed by 20 000
people and she's like I'm flirting with
you
yeah
you want to play games Stockholm
Syndrome
I was like okay
damn but yeah that's uh that's where it
all started and now he's part of the
church and we're gonna get yeah we're
gonna go through the temperatures family
in the church yes damn I wish uh damn I
wish I recorded some of my Utah set
because then you would appreciate um
on the second day I performed there was
like a fire going on and I was like
which one of your extremist uncles threw
his third wife in the barbecue pit and
started that fire right I know dark as
hell it was my uncle yeah
[Laughter]
playing Halo
uh yeah a grown-up Mormon it was
difficult I had friends that weren't
Mormon and so they just like wouldn't
invite me to parties yeah because they
didn't want me judging them of course I
remember I found out my friend Got
Fingered and I lectured her she didn't
do that till marriage she's like you
you're gonna this is a mistake you're
gonna regret this wow she's fine now
yeah that's good no we were worried she
made it yeah fingered at 16 years old
God forbid crazy you know that leads to
that two fingers I prayed for her that's
probably why she came out good yeah yeah
I saved her you saved her if you didn't
go to church and just ask God every day
please save my friend who had the finger
in her
shoes Lord knows where she would have
ended up dude